hello everybody
are we live welcome back to the stream
welcome to the egg shock egg shock
challenge the Easter the Easter egg hunt
shock collar challenge but before we do
anything during the 30-minute break that
we had just now that is some whompin EDM
wait hold on wait there's a shock collar
with this yeah no it said it was yes so
all right but before we do that the
final number is 66 thousand nine hundred
and forty eight in the 30-minute break
I've said and I promise that I will
match from the end of the last one to
the beginning of this one I'm gonna
match a grand total of it's almost tempo
yeah it is isn't it it's eight thousand
o57 350 it was fifty seven thousand
three hundred and fifty dollars donated
at the end of the last one listen thank
you
nine thousand five hundred ninety-eight
dollars so - well - one night run it up
to a nice a nice ninety about nine ten
thank you
you know what I will but to a nice ten
yeah I'm gonna do a nice ten thousand
right there I'm donating it right now
live if I can get into lives I mean
how's that YouTube ad pocalypse yeah
we'll have to sing well mark no no no no
you don't have this thing about me cuz
unfortunately
I'm happy to do it don't get rum I'm not
I'm not unhappy I'm doing it right now
I'm not unfortunately I can't make this
donation I'm a man of my word and I'm
gonna do it right exactly now because I
right here
doing that thing like now it's happening
there we go and then BOOM alright I just
donated $10,000 to save the children
because I promised that I would match
that donation so everything that you
donated during that gap was tripled
because everything that you donated was
not only matched by me but was matched
by an anonymous donor if you didn't know
and this is the first screen that you're
seeing welcome very much thank we
welcome welcome but also there's an
anonymous donator that if we hit our 200
thousand dollar goal they will match
that and we will race up to four hundred
thousand dollars hold on just math wise
I think it's quadrupled because you
matched and then they're matching both
of them so quadrupled it that is
technically true it's it's the value of
squares but the value of squares that
doesn't apply to this is ad pocalypse
has really hit pretty hard here March
blériot skew so uh with that $10,000
donation and considering this is the
one-year anniversary of our doing these
charity streams
don't let someone go I just want to say
in my defense that the ad pocalypse has
also struck me down so I think that is
unfair to fire me hold up in my defense
I don't really have that much to fall
back on so this would hurt me a lot so I
you have a you have a channel to fall
back on
you're also she on let's try you've got
all kinds of stuff you're young and spry
you heard him I am young and spry yeah
but we'll decide that later we'll let
you guys decide who needs to go and know
you you can't vote for me that's just
not how this works
yeah wait why can't you why can't you
just pass your channel on to somebody
else
chica we'll take it over that's how many
people do way better that doesn't fix
anything at all well actually no they'd
be way more abused if do you get took
over yeah which is why I'm doing jiggers
world she's probably mad we got to get
down to business because not up two
things happen that are very important
two things number one of which is that
we hit 77,000 now correct which means
that we unlocked another hidden hidden
hidden hidden hidden what's his name oh
this one's called kinky okay remember I
came up with all these ideas myself and
then with everything so kinky is a
secret you'll you'll find out if we get
it but I'm adding number 21 to the dunk
tank
and both of you should go because we hit
to ten thousands on the way there [ __ ]
that's right we also have to do all
right we're the new ones in there at the
same time okay all right I'll be over
here okay here I'll do all do all those
Scooby Doo
Oh someone pointing at something in
there what yes we had more hi to other
donators last time around we'll do that
we'll get to those just as soon as we
get this done you guys ah
this is a beautiful thing I'm sure Bob
would appreciate this I mean if anyone
maybe I can call Bob to see if you but I
want to see what he thinks of this if he
even answers which he probably won't
77077 No number one oh that sucks for
you
Oh No that's the same thing all right
well it's only fair oh it seems fair
well that means yeah that makes sense
Oh Bob's not available for FaceTime well
that's a bunch of baloney that's so cool
well alright so one is Chronicles of
Riddick which just means that he's
blindfolded and has headphones on that
makes him can't able to hear anything so
that's gonna kind of assist him in this
one
Ethan yeah all right nice you got it hey
then come on Hazen you got it you got it
you're right there
you're right there that is so much oh no
you got P come on I believe in you I
believe in you so much you got this
which one come on come on get it you got
it
it's gonna be good for your skin you got
this
it's tightening up those young pores why
are the young pores saying Oh young and
supple he is sometimes supple Bob all
right Bob wait oh babe I need to help
you fit Bob hey Bob I want you to see
something here got this bucket here
we're it's called bobbing for punishment
[Laughter]
yeah so Bob what do you think about all
this no oh you just bit it you've got a
hole in it you just fell out so that's
yours
is that seven wait is that seven or is
that - and you bit off part of it seven
yeah you get it you get it yeah yeah
it's funny right have you seen the board
look at you I don't write it's good
stuff all right see you Bob okay Bob
wait he's gone
he's already out of here wait what was
clever girl huh clever girl oh you get
to where the t-rex costumes did you
replace the batteries I did okay good
all right so we're having whoa we will
skit security during t-rex sketti has to
technically be before so it might give
him an advantage because we did get
sketti you know what actually sketti
after skinny yep no how could he know it
would all stay in the suit and beed win
no I'll put it in the suit okay I mean I
don't know how I wouldn't put it in the
suit but I'll try
okay good luck all right so all that
aside we are here to raise money for
Save the Children we have some big
donators of
- cheer out in just a second we're
getting set up for the egg Easter egg
hunt shot-caller challenge which means
we're going to be blindfolded with a
shock collar on our neck and it's going
to be set to a low safe setting by the
way this is not peanut butter this is
almond butter Ethan is totally fun we're
gonna have that on our neck and we're
gonna be hunting around for eggs and
when we find an egg we have to then
smash it on our head like the egg
Roulette challenge if it's not if it's
raw then we lose if it's a hard-boiled
egg we get a point right makes sense
whoever has the most points at the end
wins
wherever's it has the least amount of
points loses has to take a punishment
not only that but we have to play a game
that I made up called don't forget your
spaghetti as a part of the punishment
that we did in the last round don't
forget it in your spaghetti don't forget
a your spaghetti works like the sleep
you have to have this spaghetti outside
of the bag on your person somehow
whether that's in your pockets down your
pants in your mouth doesn't matter you
have to hold it through the entirety of
the game at the end of the game we will
measure who has the most about a
spaghetti leftover these are equivalent
amounts of spaghetti do I have to be
blindfolded when I'm putting spaghetti
in my pockets no maybe I don't know yes
no yes No
so what oh God
okay you can unmute me now look dude
this is gonna be hard cuz my arms I
don't have a lot of reeds
yeah that's unfortunate for you I'm hot
by the way I'm totally flying but we
need your help through this because but
we need your help through this
throughout this entire stream we're
still raising money for a great cause if
you have not donated yet please do take
the time to make a donation I just
donated ten thousand dollars of my own
money because it was matched now I'm not
gonna be able to do that again
but throughout the entirety of this
stream this entire event that we're
doing we've got five more events that
we're doing after this one and we've got
so much left so much fun to have but we
are what is it we are three eights three
eights of our way to our goal and we
need to keep that momentum going if
we're ever gonna reach this $200,000
goal and the only way that we're gonna
do that is by you helping us not only
through donations but also by sharing
the stream count I'm gonna be as
shameless as I possibly can be because
of how important this is please spread
the word about this stream about the
charity donation page please spread the
word about everything that we can
possibly do because this is what matters
this is what's important and if you guys
and if you guys can help us out and just
take the time to let people know on
Facebook and Twitter where this is i've
already tweeted it out i've posted on
facebook about this particular stream
tell your friends about it
use the hashtag babcock for andrew
Babcock who is the first thousand dollar
donator on our stream in addition to
hope anyway they'll get $3,000 donator
on our stream and was an amazing person
and is the hashtag that we're using to
conglomerate all the fan art that we
have but please I really mean it I'm
really asking guys make a donation if
you can I'll reach out to friends and
family anyone that can make any sort of
contribution to this campaign because
now more than ever
it means double the entire way through
not just when I was matching but the
entire stream it is matching
for a great cause that is helping
children all around the globe okay okay
all right let's get to this who's that
not a dinosaur bring the spaghetti am I
going first yeah you're doing first
I'm just getting this okay oh wait love
I need bathroom you have a bow on ya
blindfold yourself do you have the app
Catherine oh yeah y'all get the app cuz
it's Bluetooth can you huh just go on
the app store
what idiot you have it on your phone
writings you're fine just stand right
what stay right there okay no your eat
Ethan you go okay go can you hand me
that one thank you
am I supposed to be doing something Amy
come come no get over here Oh get over
we are controlling it
do you we explain to everything that
we're doing there even I'd either just
hit sit tight stairs no don't move
backwards I am a giant you can very
anyway uh-huh mixing to your collar okay
so I'm holding the collar what have you
got it on it on okay
so green
yep it was green is this supposed to
stay green okay hold on wait don't do
anything yet it's on my arm that's the
vibration setting it did it vibrate yeah
okay cool
here's number one do you want me to just
put it up two three go for it two three
do you want me to shock you yeah Dingle
all right put it on an extreme setting
but we do have it on a relative setting
so what I'm gonna do yeah the spaghetti
wait why do you have it on what why do
you have it on nothing why I'm going
first
he just has that oh yeah that's nice
understand any
we got more weight you have to do two
things first Tony Toth a we got to put a
put a name on there yeah I'll do it I'll
do it huh
stop it where's the marker it's in there
yep all right I don't like this I can't
see anything so I feel like I'm gonna
talk over some really loud toady
[Music]
it's also here right
read on - also shout out - we don't
whisper with a thousand dollar donation
and ie don't whisper please don't move
your body
we don't whisper we shout loud you're
the greatest person around I love you
and only you no one else not even chica
saying that but thank you so much we
don't whisper also we don't whisper on
YouTube go look them up they're probably
pretty cool I think probably but thank
you so much for all your donations thank
you everybody that's contributed we can
keep this going we can keep this
donation train going we really
appreciate you all being here we're
almost at eighty thousand dollars
donated we are rolling right through
this and then we're gonna hit don't
forget to your spaghetti and then we're
gonna we're gonna carry on through it's
gonna be a great trick are you done yet
hey you go sorry I forgot about my head
ah there we are
oh that's the good stuff right there I'm
gonna Sharpie by the speak all right
Tyler put the spaghetti in your pocket
okay carry this here Oh
put spaghetti in you so don't forget
your spaghetti just to be also very
clear about it we have to take the
spaghetti and we have to carry it with
us
well that's not very fair wait no
outside you can't have the bag in there
no I know well what do you have
what do you really don't know Oh God
oh I've already dropped some sketti ah
all right uh captain will you please
mute my mic so they don't hear the the
things and it's horrible for their ears
the sloppiness I think that's the only
reason they want to be in this stream
right now oh okay
getting a little in eighty thousand
dollars raised thank you so much we will
do another punishment but we got to get
this game underway or else we're never
gonna get to it ah ah that's go get e on
the blood uh I didn't know that
sensation before this date but now I
know it now I am very familiar ah okay
all right I've got a lot of spaghetti
still left I don't know I don't know how
you did oh I don't know I'm quiet
because I know I yeah really louder I
came here I don't think it is to be
perfectly honest yes stay in one spot
alright so here's how it's gonna work
we've got boiled eggs that we've got raw
eggs I'm gonna put on this blindfold and
then my associates here are going to
place them all about the table if I
don't touch what I'm supposed to touch
Ethan will shock me because Tyler can't
see it
Tyler Tyler Tyler Tyler oh yeah yeah put
the eggs hide them okay how much time
wait no it's not time thing oh yeah
there's a lot of crap on the table
because if I don't touch an egg I get
shocked right we didn't test this
beforehand so this is probably not gonna
go very well I have to wait for it to
reinflates okay you do that
all right so continue the donations
coming along if you look down in the
description below there's a link to the
Tulsa five-page Tulsa fine comm slash at
market Blair where you can make a
donation where you can see all the
wonderful people that have made a
donation so far
please give deeply share widely thank
you so much and we'll get this underway
sound good awesome you can bring me back
alright what Kathleen you can bring me
back there we go okay alright put those
eggs there and let me know when I'm I
need to go alright so when you don't
grab an egg you get shocked right okay
Ethan what I need your help mixing them
up cuz I can't see [ __ ]
okay we're get out of the way get out of
the way move move move okay just just
move okay all these eggs it's about to
be put on the thing how many eggs how
many eggs we doing I don't know okay
connector teacher eyes derp
Amy is this legal
good idea okay so much of this t-rex is
getting in my mouth hmm okay how many
eggs are we doing okay Tyler no more
eggs Tyler no more wine okay okay good
yep I'll take that stuff mixed up or do
I need to move it no no don't move
anything all right I'm ready
hold on I am NOT wait all right so mark
Oh Tyler stop moving you've got one two
three four five six seven eight nine why
are you touching me oh of course I'm a
human seven to t-rex costume who else
would I be there are 17 eggs why I don't
know should there be less I don't know
all right all right go ahead whenever
you're ready
try and get an egg what are you doing
Tyler stop coming towards me no go the
other way go the other way
nope that is a plate ah okay no not Niki
I am very sorry I'm very sorry I just
want to make this very clear that is I
think I'm so sorry I don't want to be
doing this to you No don't do it I don't
want to hurt you like this I'm being too
blue I'm so sorry
yep yes okay oh and can I still lose
weight so now what the woman treats
boxing we keep
going until all the eggs are gone yeah
okay
now who you who I don't want to
you are gonna go hurt it's not the worst
thing but it's shocking there's some egg
on that I really don't want to do this
bad you have to do this because we're
here for charity there get this in there
while you can't do i'll close you up
wait hold on stay it's not it's not yeah
Tyler stop that why are you just
touching things
stop don't mess up the thing okay hold
on this is hard okay can I not put it on
my neck no you have to put it on your
neck
which one's the shock button the yellow
on a sweet yes here Shay how do you
spell it can he give me can you give me
a two guys but you need to see yeah
children just attest it's good yeah just
tell about everything is doubled stakes
are double oh wait hold on wait - I'm
doubled doubled do a three do all my
time oh okay all right cool Shay thank
you so much we're gonna write on Tyler
turn around turn around turn around
you're not that death turn around
alright here we go
alright Shay we all we love you hey eat
eat eat Shane thank you so much we love
you
Oh shame
[Applause]
you're awesome I've got egg on my hands
are you good not yet we have to wait to
inflate okay all right then so I'm gonna
mix up these because Tyler is absolutely
hopeless am i am i fully zipped by the
way yes okay does it look like I'm
inflating well also there are bonus
apples here if they touch an apple they
have to take that punishment so that's
just added fun in it fun is the right
word right okay good
plus for a test will you give me a 1 and
then a 2 nope okay all right you ready I
guess
all right go I hate this
well too bad much hmm I'm so afraid dude
I'm so afraid I really don't want to do
anything oh you're okay I am a t-rex
you're all right I have a t-rex how much
does it hurt you'll find out okay commit
commit Ethan you've got this there's so
many stop touching me you got it stop
touching me I'll murder you in your
sleep I'm so brave I just touch stop
touching me that was my with me god damn
it I'm so afraid oh that was not an egg
I mean oh I have to pee okay
okay close to something maybe maybe
hello egg
are you there boy egg egg come come come
here egg come here a my string farther
away way off target okay I'm gonna go
over here alright alright good idea huh
huh egg
oh really bad what if I touch truth
paste well I didn't even feel anything
sorry
no no like I didn't feel that okay no
like I felt that all right think that I
touched anything okay inch forward okay
Oh God God Oh
it really hurts oh yes
yeah should I take off the costume oh
yeah just get it in there wait suck a
hand in wait oh I just stepped a hundred
percent okay why don't you just tuck
your hand in that makes sense and then
I'll wait I'll take the egg oh yeah no
that's fine - yeah hold on so I don't be
inflate please I will hold your hand
blind no can you see me no not you then
can you even see my head yes okay
oh so much I have to say this is raised
against me because they like heart it's
wrong angular's let's say oh no wait I
think these are all raw eggs no Nana are
there a few that are the rubber ones
they're a half of cooked okay
I'm gonna take off the dog collar okay
all right so that's two negative point
that's no points for me or even Tyler
cheer up
all right got it okay all right Tyler
here put this on
then slid all the way down to my pants
Oh
in my pain worse than death slowly can
we do it I've never felt oh can we test
that my hand first no I'll give you a
one-way where should I place I'll give
you a one here okay on the side of the
neck is good right here yeah
all right here's the one oh holy cow
those are the ones where I do not like
this what did you guys have it at I was
the one we had it at three no I don't
like this that was a one there's a -
okay it's fine okay your turns up so if
you grab an egg you're fine
we have a mix go wait hang on we have to
mix and match for them I've been blind
well I don't know you could have heard
the eggs you couldn't really like it
here you could have I mean I'm just
saying it's a possibility the eggs like
have options this is gonna hurt so bad
you don't know that all right how am I
going know going on hang on stop all
right go ahead go go
is it does it do I get zapped if I just
touch the table no tables fine oh that
touch ha ha ha
I don't like this ha ha ha
feel the pain way off really uh oh you
that's the that see edge completely
wrong there we go
there that is the other coordinate find
it out feel it a deep I just got
disoriented that's tough [ __ ]
I guess oh he's getting really close to
something
mm-hmm
I think we should bump it up to a 10
turns mean high empowered poet not that
yep okay that's a punishment Apple that
look that has been Apple to punish me
now the punishment is that I mean I have
to take this off no that means you get a
bonus egg that was that wasn't an egg ah
is there anything in the eggs yes is
there I believe so
are there things in these eggs were
those eggs go oh they're in the blue
wait do it keep going yeah keep going
we'll give you the egg later hey you
guys did you guys help each other at all
no you're fine
Oh mmm what is that that's an egg hey
smash it on yo hands on your head
should I take this off first no Ryan raw
is it raw very raw put it on your head
like everyone likes slam it on your head
like everybody else did Troy sorry that
I got so upset that's rough I am NOT the
sink I am NOT the sink I am NOT the sink
here we go wait keep going keep going
keep going
all right there you're there all right
nobody got points which means we got to
go for a round two oh no wait show how
they do the punishment egg first oh yeah
Oh careful where you squeeze what's in
this well we're about to find out oh no
so with these punishment eggs these eggs
are made of rubber
I'm assuming you cut them in half and
you can put anything inside of them so
Katherine Amy put things inside of them
this morning we have no idea what are in
any of these and there's a done a dozen
of these so Tyler is about to follow
this on his head and he has no idea what
it's okay since I'm here here careful
that's your punishment egg
you can either smash it on your head or
eat what's inside open it in your head
or open it in your mouth head her mouth
head okay
but is that what is what is that dump it
on your head I thought I did
squeeze it oh all right round two good
I'm feeling I'm gonna go okay huh ah can
I take off this we raise costume we oh
yeah that's right let's take off the
t-rex in the blindfold you're good
Tyler take it off scanning what do you
look like you're you're like uh uh like
some kind of injured War veteran coming
home like you look like you've been
through hell that was a really tight on
my eyes so I got yes see anything those
eggs are all far away how did I end up
not touching like a million things and
that shot is so scary
I know right well you did touch a
million things and now I get to go again
but this time I want to actually give
him has anybody dropped their sketti no
you owe me though yes we do we will get
a punishment it's my turn okay hang on
I cut so much spaghetti oh my bad okay
all right
am I allowed to take this off my head no
oh my love that would have been disaster
I was very close to disaster right then
and there lunatic wait this my Apple
from the egg thing go in there now
where's that stay on the table okay okay
Oh what number is that nice grab by the
[Applause]
Telmo Kinky's about ah because I
actually don't know kinky is one of the
is the special punishment that was real
this round only kinky uh is where you
have to be bound and gagged I can give
that a good rinse before you put that oh
no oh no it's gonna be adventurous this
is no ball gag this is what I do show go
right in his mouth ah he's not really
good percent real Rudolph nose what I
think he had a red light and also I
don't want to put Rudolph's nose in my
mouth I also think that Rudolph wasn't
really into that kind of stuff I don't
know well can you guys washed your head
off
yeah so they told me I wasn't allowed to
say that oh okay alright mister come
here they're gonna put my love back on
okay sorry for all the rubbing everybody
okay now wait don't we have handcuffs as
well where are those zip ties hmm what
it's duct tape oh it's duct tape yeah we
didn't we didn't have any handcuffs no
oh we tried to get all this stuff during
Black Friday issues we have many shots
are you trying to talk here I'm sorry
are you just as well huh who was it
Rachel Rachel Rachel I haven't gotten a
tat in a while let's get you a tat
where's that alright oh it's so eggy
alright alright RA chal
is how you smell I can't look at my
[ __ ] stamp 1 I can't look mmm try doing
away with this I'm also gonna put this
so we don't rip your arm hair and tear
skin off with the duct tape hmm is that
tight enough mm-hmm all right oh we can
get real cheney and use chicas colorful
very kinky what have we done we'll do
much for charity why are you doing it so
much this is real kinky
so Tyler oh wait let's uh let's mix
these up first
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so I mixed them up
Oh got a good mix okay so get ready oh
wait connecting your dog collar
mm-hm so the yellow one is the shock
okay all right mark whenever you're
ready whoa whoa where is it it's right
here oh yeah okay we need a tight
knitter okay all right whatever you're
ready sir very raw oh hey how is that
experience Oh how did he get it in two
tries on boo boo boo boo boo
put that put that down oh you got Roy I
don't want you use my phone with a bunch
of rice baby
okay let me know I'm gonna interpret for
what he's saying whoa don't do that no
okay oh no I got it he's got a mask up
first
hmm so much raw egg it's just going
right onto my eye all right so far
but who or what cause has it been
rearranged tell me the fool oh boy can
you can you just leave I just really
don't wanna step on the eggs but I'm
gonna move you so you don't I got you
Wow Wow a little bit looser please okay
right foot I'm in a month I'm gonna put
towels over it so oh okay thank you
that's very nice oh very nice very nice
I hope everybody's enjoying this dream
it might be a little weird but you know
where happened are you guys having fun
well I'm having fun I'm having fun this
is a good time this is a good time
mm-hmm all right am i good you are good
mm-hmm right here yep you're good
am I in the middle you're close one
slide step
now you're on the metro yeah you got it
mm-hmm
okay Wow Wow Wow
it just feels like somebody rated like
Steve was like attack just like quickly
like keep going [ __ ] oh I'm sorry sorry
that I'm taking so long
oh my god
yeah
Oh your your hand was I can tell okay
wait do you want me to do my egg now me
oh yes do you want to pick it for me
okay all right
oh you guys did some like Oh oh here's
some eggs myself all right I'm gonna do
this one okay
that hurts so bad okay
all right so this one I everything in
these is edible right yes yes okay
nothing's gonna hurt Oh nothing's gonna
hurt me right do I have to eat the whole
thing
yes oh yeah why would you eat it that is
all olive oil it's good for your hair oh
very oily skin as it is this is going to
trickle down under my face I'm going to
just walk over to the sink and then dip
my head mmm just gonna leak a little bit
yes are you can trying to eat than
controlling all wall up oh geez I don't
I don't like you
with the charge the zapper whoa
I just I scares me all right oh where am
I am I in the center
what oh yeah readjust where's the egg
spot even I mean there isn't one well
there's there's an egg spot that I
covered in paper towels it's right in
front of you okay oh yes a lot of olive
oil
ah very good how much time do we have
left for this game ten minutes okay
Oh what go ahead Tyler mm-hmm try and
get your eggs doing marks point system
Oh mother trucker did you turn it up her
game Oh got a stick I don't know where I
was last night
the house there nothing there
oh very good
now give it a good bash it's me rock
paper so let me take this off 0:04 not
the loser
know who winner is loser or whoa whoa
two out of three
so ha ha I will be the referee all right
and begin losing easy oh you need this
off don't you hmm
you can speak again oh my jaw there oh
that that can't be fly my hair still
smells like pickle juice mmm that is
something that I've never imagined that
I would be undertaking but now I'm just
gonna go ahead and dive into the bob
bucket and hopefully drown anyway this
is well I've got so much spaghetti in my
pocket okay I did God do this quickly so
we can get the spaghetti out and find
out who the second loose go ahead Bob
you're right flop
wait let's let's I'll take care take my
log don't pinch the card all right go
ahead there's not a ton of paint residue
just a good amount
nice you've got good suction Thank You
11 soggy croco ha ha ha
damn it I actually wanted that one
because it's funny we start the next
stream with soggy crop socks I'll do it
with you if you want oh you will I'll
suffer along side oh thank you can you
put that back on please hmm
and we got one more thing to do before
we get out of here which is we got to
measure the spaghetti no all right
everybody get the spaghetti back out
okay
put it in a bowl or somehow no that's
the measuring bolster who goes first
okay
all right well we can't compare if
they're wet but get the bags okay where
are the bags go here's my bag I got
ready to put I got my bag thank you
okay this is gonna be a problem how am I
gonna do it let me cut you free why okay
that makes sense I mean you know scared
off right oh no no no no cut away no do
it but kind of wait for me I just don't
trust at all what are you doing what but
then you're just screaming while I do it
what well I guess I'm just gonna be here
then I'm just you know it's fine just
it's fine get my spaghetti but get
getting it into the bag how equal
amounts of spaghetti were there in each
bag ah no well and that counts - yep
that counts Oh No
oh no my spaghetti don't forget
get in there we should have done was
like weighed these out Oh give it a
sniff who hocked a loogie on me oh my
god I was looking for the purple ones
and off there give me this hellhole
alright I lose ah it's gonna dump headin
to try to forget everything this
happening now oh you got my lob okay
okay all right go ahead
oh god there's so much oh that's so
gross there's like fully for Louise
maybe I don't know they're always gonna
make me pee alright mister man pick your
poison
oh just put it on my head any one of
them yeah go for it
alright is there a worst one in here no
water one please water
Oh soy sauce
no it's because destiny oh okay why is
Ethan's colorful oh oh because of my
shirt cuz I put it on my shirt oh okay
Johnny
we raised eighty eight thousand dollars
we'll start the next one with soggy
crock sauce just means we're gonna put
hair gel in a sock and I have to wear
those insights and crocks
so thank you everybody so much for
joining us we're gonna be back in just
thirty minutes we're gonna clean up
hopefully we're gonna clean up and then
we're gonna be starting again in thirty
minutes in that time please share the
donation I can't match again but please
share out that donation link please tell
people about the next stream that we're
gonna be doing please let people know
what we're doing here today and how far
we have left to go we have raised eighty
eight thousand dollars which means that
we have a hundred and twelve thousand
dollars left until we hit our goal now
we've got five more challenges that
we're gonna be doing all day long but we
need your help we really undeniably need
your help because it's you guys that
make this happen so just tell people
that their donation is gonna be doubled
it goes straight to Save the Children
we don't make a penny we don't touch the
money it goes straight to the
organization and it does a world of good
so please we can raise $400,000 today
but only with your help share post
fanart use hashtag Babcock do everything
you can in your power to spread the word
about this right now so thank you so
much we'll see you in 30 minutes and uh
okay go get cleaned up